I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello, everybody. Good morning. Oh, it's morning for us. Our good evening. We don't know when you listen. We don't. Although I'm always fascinated. I love it when people share where they listen and when and what they're doing. I just love it.
A lot of people listen while they do chores. Yeah. I think that's a good time to listen. I do too. I had one gal say she sneaks and listens at work. Oh. What does she do? I don't know. I should always do the follow-up question. Hmm. Don't know what you do at work. But thanks for listening to us. I hope everything else in your office is safely going about its business.
Yes. I hope you're having a good day at work. Mm-hmm. Today is lecture circuit part two. It is season five, episode 17, written by Mindy Kaling and directed by Ken Quapas. Here's the summary. Pam and Michael are still on their speaking tour because, remember, Michael was asked by David Wallace to tell all the other branches how to be as successful as Scranton. Mm-hmm. Well, they've decided to take a detour.
They're going to add Nashua to the lecture circuit so that Michael can see Holly and get some closure. And Pam is all about it. Pam's up for it. Yeah. But guess what? What? Holly's not there.
Oh, no. You know who is there? AJ. Holly's new boyfriend. New boyfriend. Oh. Back in Scranton, Jim and Dwight are still trying to do right by Kelly's missed birthday. And Angela has a very new, expensive cat that she bought with the money from selling her
engagement ring from Andy. And she has to keep tabs on it with a whole video system. Not even just keep tabs. She's delighted to just watch her cats while she's at work. That's what she's doing while she's at work. Yeah. Exactly. Well, fast fact number one, if you listened last week, then you'll remember that we explained
how lecture circuit was originally meant to be a single episode. But when they got to the editing room, it was just so good, they decided to turn it into two. Yeah. Jenna, weren't you so surprised when you started watching this one, even though I knew that information? Because we talked about that last week. On the screen, it said previously on the office.
Yes. And then there was a whole recap. Never seen that before. Never. Not very documentary. Not very documentary. Well, they had to add extra stories in order to make it two episodes. Remember last week, they had the story of Andy trying to date Stanley's client.
Well this week, the extra storyline is all about Angela and her cats. Oh, yeah. Angela, I texted with Mindy about this. You did? I did. What did she say? She said, she thought that on paper, that that cat storyline was a little broad and a little silly, but here was a thing that the writers knew about you, Angela.
What? And this is something that Jen Salata said. Remember back in the duel, that you do such a great job of grounding comedy and making it work. And so they could just throw these broader storylines at you and you made them sing. She said, what a gift. Let me tell you something. I am on cloud nine right now.
I am absolutely giddy. Mindy and Jen Salata's opinion of my acting and comedic skills mean more to me than any award you heard me. I will take this Mindy and Jen award to my heart. I'm going to make you a little Mindy Jen and a little Mindy Mindy statue and give them to you. Is that weird if I have a miniature statue? Okay, Mindy and Jen, if you hear this, it's because I so highly regard your opinion.
You just won a Mindy today. Oh! And on the duel, you won a Jen. Thank you. Yeah. I'd like to thank the Academy of Badass Women for believing in me. Fast fact number two is a location breakdown. Let's discuss the Nashua branch.
I was really hoping you would. Everyone's curious because we did not go to Nashua. We filmed the exterior and interior scenes at different places. The exterior of the Nashua branch was actually T&R Drywall in Van Nuys. Huh. Yep. Then we relocated to get this. Where?
For the interior scenes. Where? M&M Paper Company. A real paper company. That's amazing. Right? Yeah. We shot all of the scenes for Nashua at the very end of the week.
It was on a Friday and the very last thing we shot was Steve cutting the sleeve off Holly's sweater. Oh! That was the last thing. But here's something else that we shot that day that I found fascinating. Here's a little bit of, like, I don't know, is this movie magic, something- Well, you tell me and I'll tell you. Insidery Hollywood.
Yeah, tell me. We shot a background plate. Oh, that's very Insidery Hollywood movie magic-y. Yes. Thank you. Thank you. So a background plate is a shot that they could put behind a future talking head that might take place in Nashua.
So it's just like an empty background. And they could superimpose a person there with a green screen. So if AJ or Holly or anyone from the Nashua branch had a talking head in a future episode, we wouldn't have to rent this whole building again. They could just shoot it on a green screen and add our background plate. It is really cool. I've only worked with the background plate one time. It's for a TV show I shot this year.
I don't know if I can say yet, but we had to be driving through Los Angeles and we were in a car Jenna on a rig and it would move. Yes. But we were inside a studio and then all around us was this sort of like curved screen of like the streets of Los Angeles. And I got dizzy. This is the thing you don't think about in acting school, which is you're going to do a fakey car scene with fakey street going by.
And it might make you a little dizzy if you're prone to that. Now could you see the fake street on the screen? Yes. No, it was surrounding us. Wow. Like, you know, one of those fancy movie theaters where the screen goes around you. I don't know. They have those, don't they?
Yeah, I think so. Somewhere. Something like that. Yeah. It like went around us. So we would look out the car window and there'd be the street driving by. Wow. Not the street driving by.
You know what I mean? I know what you meant. I did a fakey driving scene like that in a studio as well, except it was just a green screen and they inserted the images later. But I was on a little thing where they make the car move and it's, yeah, fans blowing in through the windows. Yes. For motion.
Yes. Yeah. Movie magic. Movie magic. I love doing that stuff because that's some of the stuff as a kid that was fascinating to me. Yeah. The fakey movie magic.
It's also like so fascinating, sorry guys to go off on a total tangent here. Great to see that many different departments working to pull off one moment. I always think that's so cool. Yeah. All right, Angela, this next location breakdown is all you. Will you please tell us where was Angela's apartment such that we could see all your cats on camera? Oh, will I?
I have a whole cat camera location breakdown. And then later, Jenna, I have a cat guest star breakdown. Oh, I can't wait for that. You will not want to miss it. All right, so you guys, Angela's living room was built on stage two. That was inside our warehouse set. Remember the warehouse where we go? Yes, of course.
Okay. We would build a lot of those swing sets. Swing sets. Yeah. We'll turn for you. They shot the scenes individually and then later they took the one scene with all the cats and they burned that into the computer screen. They also burned into the computer screen at my desk the one of me with the cats.
Does that make sense? Okay. A little bit. You burned it far prior to when you did the scenes at your desk because then what is burning it onto your computer screen mean? I think that's the term Randy used. I think it just means uploading it, right? In post-production, they were able to like take the clips and put them on my computer
so that Kevin and Oscar really watched those. Oh, so they didn't have to imagine what they were seeing. No, they really got to watch that. How delicious was that? Also when we all gathered around to watch the cats on the screen, you know, when it's Meredith and the whole gang, we're really watching the cats. Oh, okay. That's amazing.
So you were really just over in our warehouse set. That's right. I worked all day in the warehouse. Many times when you went to Angela's apartment, even years later when you went to Oscar's apartment, that was all in the warehouse. Wow. Mm-hmm. The interior shots, I should say.
Yes. Fast fact number three, we have a big guest star alert. We do. It's AJ Holly's boyfriend played by Rob Hubel. Yeah. Now, Rob is a very successful improviser, actor, writer, Emmy-nominated producer. He's like a quadruple threat. That is four.
That is four. Yeah. A double-double threat? Yeah, he's a double-double threat. He's been in over 140 films and television shows. Good lord. He was very recently and transparent with Melora Hardin, little office reunion there. And Angela, you know Rob.
I do know Rob. I mean, I met him a long time ago through our mutual friend, Rachel Harris. Here plays Angela Martin's sister. It's that little like LA comedy club circle, you know, between the groundlings and improv and stuff. Rob is very funny. He's also just delightful to talk to because he's just one of these people to me, kind of like Will Ferrell, who's just walks into the room funny.
He's friendly. And he's friendly. Yeah. So I knew this episode was coming up and I was like, we got to reach out to Rob. We need to hear his story about how he came to be on the office and he's going to answer a few questions for us throughout this episode. Well, here is how he got his job on the office. Hey guys, it's Rob Hubel.
It's early in the morning. So my voice is a little crackly. Well these ladies will tell you that sometimes in Hollywood you get offered parts, but it's kind of few and far between. And I think the great Allison Jones cast this show and I had done some movies that Allison had cast. So that may have helped me maybe get offered the part. But I also might have been offered the part because I knew Steve Carell from The Daily
Show. I worked at The Daily Show before I got into comedy. I worked as a producer on a lot of shows. And I worked at The Daily Show when Steve Carell and Stephen Colbert were there. In fact, I shared an office with Nancy Walls, who is married to Steve Carell, the great Nancy Walls. And so that all may have helped me get just offered the part. Otherwise, if that wasn't the case, I probably had a great audition because I'm great at
auditioning. But I was very lucky and nervous because the show was so big and everybody had become these rock stars by that time. So I didn't want to screw it up. Aw, he did not screw it up. No, he did not. Well, Angela, we got a fan question from Joe S. Did Rob Hubel know he would have a recurring role on the show as Holly's boyfriend, or did he think that it was just one episode?
And he sent in an audio clip about that, too. I think I knew that it was a recurring part, but I didn't know what the plot was and what the story arc was. But I did know that it was going to be the new boyfriend. And I knew that Steve Carell would be giving me a hard time in those scenes. And I knew that it was with Amy Ryan, who I was such a fan of because I just finished watching The Wire and she was on The Wire, I think season two, which is another great show.
Someone should do a podcast about The Wire, but Amy Ryan is just such a great actor also. So again, I didn't want to screw that one up. So like Angela said, Rob answered more questions. We'll sprinkle them in later. Sprinkle. Sprinkle. But you should also know that he has a weekly Twitch show with Paul Shear, which is Twitch TV slash Friend Zone, and it's live every Thursday at Five Pacific.
One more plug for Rob because I think he's so hilarious. And he does the show with my friend Erin Hayes that I did a show called Hot Wives of Orlando with. Their show is called Medical Police Guys. It's really funny. It's on Netflix. It's a spinoff of Children's Hospital. Really funny folks.
I think we should take a break and then go to Nashua and a birthday party and lick some cats. I mean, did you think you'd ever say that in a sentence? No. Today is unique. Well, you know what I didn't think I would do, but Google how to lick your cat. I can't wait for this. Okay, we begin this episode in the kitchen.
Kevin's eating two ice cream treats. He has a popsicle, you know, the double stick popsicle. Yep. And then like the ice cream cone with like the chocolate with the peanut topping thing. Yeah. What's that called again? Some kind of drumstick. That's it.
That's it. Oh, it is a drumstick. Drumstick. Yeah. Anyway, he's got both of those going. But you know what? It's because he didn't eat his lunch. Well, I mean all his lunch.
It doesn't matter. Angela enters smiling. It's strange. Beaming. So happy. Giddy. She's so happy that she looks at Kevin and you know, normal Angela would just look at him eating that double stick popsicle and the drumstick and just go off on him.
Like she says nothing. No. Actually, she says, oh, hello everyone. Oh, ice cream. Nice Kevin. Looks good. Nice Kevin. What is happening?
Well, I'll tell you what's happening. She is going to announce a new addition to her family. It's a cat, a rare special cat, a $7,000 cat. She's hypoallergenic. She doesn't struggle when you try to dress her. She's a third generation show cat. Her father was in meet the parents. Wait.
So the cat that pees on the toilet and meet the parents is somehow related to Angela's new cat. It's Princess Lady's dad. Wow. I know. Well, the gang wants to see this cat. They're like a $7,000 cat. I got to see it.
And Angela's like, I can do better than a picture. Oh, she can. She has a kitty cam set up at home. So she takes the whole gang over to her computer and they are watching these cats frolic in her living room. How many are there? I didn't count. I mean, there's lots.
There's lots. There's probably 12. I mean, there were at least seven or eight, at least in the picture. Who knows if someone was sitting in the window. We don't know. Angela, we got a lot of mail about this scene because your character mentions that she's annoyed that she can't take any time off. She doesn't have any sick days left.
And they don't recognize cat maternity. Yeah. And it's not fair that she can't take off a year like those people who have human babies. And Meredith agrees, right? Meredith says, yeah, I had my second kid just for the vacation time. Flurry of mail. I mean, it was a snowstorm of letters. Lots of people are like, how many children does Meredith have?
In Alliance, Dwight says she has two kids. In the injury, Michael says she has one kid, no husband. In Take Your Daughter to Work Day, she brings one child in. But then here, she says she has a second kid. What does the show Bible say? I'll tell you guys, the show Bible just says whatever the show says. So the show Bible is as all over the place as these episodes. I think we don't really know.
I think maybe we didn't do a good job keeping track of the children. I mean, what happens to the Senator's son? Oh, yeah, we'll get there. Children disappear and reappear all the time on our show. I think what happens is they write the episode and they don't check the show Bible first. And then the person who keeps the show Bible is like, dang it, I've got to write something in the show Bible now that contradicts what was already in the show Bible. But you know, their job is just to record what happens.
I've gotten questions quite a bit about Princess Lady. People want to know why would she sell Andy's engagement ring? One sort of really judged Angela for this on the comment boards back when the episode aired. There was a deleted talking head where she sort of explained it and I think we should hear it. As you may know, I am no longer in a relationships. It's been really stressful here. So I decided to treat myself to one of God's most perfect creations, a beautiful new cat.
It's tacky to talk about money. But she cost $7,000. Okay, you guys, judge Angela, if you will, but she's had a tough time because she's no longer in a relationships. Both of her relationships have ended and she has to work with both of them and see them every day. She's sort of been shunned, kicked off the party planning committee and she went and made an impulse buy to make herself feel better.
Here's what I'll say. She should have given the ring back. I know that. I know that. Because she was unfaithful. Yes. You know, the ring is a symbol of your promise, of your contract to be married and I think that if the person who has the ring breaks that contract, they should return it.
But I believe that etiquette says that if the person who gave the ring breaks the contract, you get to keep the ring. Well Angela Martin's going to use hers to buy a cat. She broke with the etiquette. Yes. Okay. I mean, that's what your character would do. Do you think Pam gave Roy the ring back?
I do. Right? Yeah. Now listen, you might throw some shade at Angela Martin. Her affair was very out there, but I think Pam had an emotional affair. You think? Of course she did. So I'm just saying.
That's why I think Pam gave the ring back. Well, Princess Lady is here folks. Yes. Well, speaking of people who are excited today, Jim is thrilled to have purchased Kelly an ice cream cake. He's putting it in the freezer. He's so proud of himself. He did it.
But then he hears Dwight yelling, screaming at Kelly. Right in her face. Dwight does this. Remember when he got right in Phyllis' face? Yes. Did they laugh a lot during this scene? I don't know how Mindy kept it together. I'm sure.
All right. Well, the reason Dwight is interrogating Kelly is because last week he looked in her files, trying to figure out when her exact birthday was, and he finds out that she was in juvie when she was 14. And now he wants to know why. I have one thing I have to bring up. I don't know why this bugged me so much, but it totally bugged me. I did that thing where I paused the TV and I talked to the TV.
What? By myself. What? I paused it and I said, what in the correct spelling of her name been on her juvenile detention record? I thought the same thing. Guys, later in the episode, Jim is going to misspell her name on the cake and I thought, my goodness.
Yeah. He has a whole talking head. Still don't know how to spell her name. Maybe look on the form in Dwight's hand. I don't know, guys. Listen, Jim and Dwight are not good communicators. They're not sharing information. Clearly.
They're not. Well, Jim is going to try to cheer Kelly up by showing her this birthday cake. He's so proud of. Who's lurking in the corner watching the whole thing? Phyllis. Phyllis. The cake is blank. Mm-hmm.
There's nothing on it. There's no theme. She hates it. I don't know why, but I became inspired to learn the history of the ice cream cake. Are you kidding? No. Is this a good place for it? Is there ever been a better place for it?
Well, here you go. Food historians? Mm-hmm. That's a job. Food historians. Fascinating. They do. They just study food?
I guess. I kind of want to be one. I want to meet one. Well, food historians believe that ice cream cakes were invented at the end of the 1600s. Who invented it? It's unclear. The recipes date back to the 1870s. And ice cream cakes were originally made from biscuits and cream.
In the Victorian era, the desserts were called balms, and they consisted of ice cream and fruit in a fancy mold. So it went through many permutations. In its early days, it was considered quite a luxury item, and it was only enjoyed by the wealthy because they were the only people who could keep it cold. Right. You'd have to get a block of ice. Yes.
Now, the ice cream cake's cousin would be a baked Alaska. That is frozen cream surrounded by meringue, but then it served hot, and there's no cake in it. A true ice cream cake has three layers. It has ice cream, cake or biscuits, and then icing or whipped cream. The leader in America for making the ice cream cake accessible and popular is... Can I guess? Can I guess?
Can I guess? Can I guess? Can I guess? Can I guess? Can I guess? Can I guess? Oh, why didn't I see that coming? Listen, I was just at Baskin Robbins with the kids because they wanted, like, afterschool
snack. Yeah. There's so many flavors. Oh, yeah. I love a Baskin Robbins ice cream cake. But it started with Carvel soft serve. Yes. That's it.
It was a small history of ice cream cake, but there you have it. Well, you know what came out of that? What? My need to meet a food historian. I mean, really? Put it on my list. I have to say, while we were talking about the history of the ice cream cake, I don't know if you noticed this, but we got really, like, kind of like, oh, wow, like, it was
very, like, precious information. It felt like it was. It is tickling me. I am tickled. When we're really into something, we get real quiet. I know the importance of it. Speaking of importance, Pam and Michael have arrived at the Nashua branch. Well, the first thing we're going to do is take a picture.
Got to take a picture. We're documenting this. Michael's very nervous as they enter. They're greeted by a really nice receptionist. Yeah. Who tells them that Holly is not there? No. She's on an HR retreat for three days.
But if you really need to get in touch with her, you can just talk to her boyfriend over there, AJ, Selzman. Jenna, I, again, paused the TV and had to talk to it because I thought, Holly, you just got transferred by corporate because you were dating a co-worker. Yeah. And now you go to this new branch of your company and immediately start dating another co-worker? Holly!
I didn't even put that together. I didn't even think of that. It's the whole reason they moved her to Nashua. Yeah, you're right. And she works in HR. I mean, if anyone should be on top of this, it's her. Holly. Well, Angie, you mentioned that the receptionist was really nice to Michael and Pam.
And we got mail about that. Baranee C said the receptionist at Nashua branch is really friendly and happily expecting Michael's arrival. She said, maybe they really don't get very many visitors, like Pam said. I think they don't. I think they're the forgotten about branch. That's what Pam said earlier. Well, the receptionist was played by actress Catherine Flynn.
Just wanted to give her a shout out for her friendly greeting. Michael has to get outside for some air. He is not doing well. No. He is about to fall apart. Yeah. In this scene, I wanted to make two observations. Okay.
Okay. One is it was really hard for me to sit on that curb and a pencil skirt and heels. And I think I did a good job. It really is hard to sit on a curb like in any kind of skirt like that because your legs don't really have anywhere to go. Yep. You can't bunch under. No.
And I had to like tuck my hands under to keep the skirt up from flapping down. Yeah. Yeah. Second, I have a windshield wiper hair going back and forth on my forehead during this entire exchange. A little hair that just goes, yep. The whole scene. And on a normal television show, they would have cut and they would have had someone come
in and just shellack your head, spray it down. We don't want any flyaways. And they would have been like holding for hair. They would have actually said flying in for a flyaway, but we didn't do that on our show. We just let stuff happen. I thought maybe this is one time since it was such an emotional scene, maybe, maybe we should have shellacked it. Were you distracted by your windshield wiper hair?
A little. You didn't notice it. I did not notice it, but now it will be all I can see when I rewatch it. Yeah. Enjoy that, everyone. Mm-hmm. Well, lady, I think we should take a break because we're going to get into the thick of Angela's cats and Michael's presentation soon and I need to center myself before both
those things happen. I think you do because I might have stories about how I created this. It was very good. Thank you. We are back in Scranton and Kevin here's, what is happening on Angela's computer screen? A lot's happening. And Mr. Ash is humping Princess Lady. Oh.
Angela's like, these are decent cats. Don't, you know, make an assumption about them and Mr. Ash is fixed and Meredith is like, I know fixed, I'm not even fixed. Meredith, Meredith and her like super gulp from 7-Eleven with her sidebar comments. Angela is so upset she has to leave. Mm-hmm. She has to go check on her cats. Yes.
Make sure Princess Lady is okay. And now, Jenna, for the cat guest star breakdown. Let's hear it. Here we go. Once again, we reached out to Bob Dunn's Animal Rentals in Silmar, California. They are going to help us create this whole cat humping scene. But first, let me tell you who played Princess Lady. Who?
Princess Lady was a Persian cat named Potato. Oh. You might have seen her if you watched the deleted scenes in the duel. She was in them, but not featured. Oh. And also, Mr. Ash, the other cat in this relationship, was played by Roswell. Roswell! Yes!
The orange cat that looks like Sunny. That's right. I remember him from your cat headshots for the duel. That's right. Now, I guess it's good that we deleted that scene because we could bring Potato back now for this lead role. Right. Yes.
Potato went from a background player to the lead of the scene. Wow. Princess Lady! I mean, that's what happens in Hollywood. That's right. You go out for one role, you're like, oh, I didn't get it, and then you get Princess Lady. Well, Randy said he loved how Bob Dunn's company listed the cats in the proposed budget.
We had seven milling about cats and two sex cats. So seven background performers and then two leads. Roswell and Potato. Our head animal trainer was Denise Sanders. She had been with us on Stress Relief. She said she required several days of training to get Roswell to pull off a believable kitty humping scene. How did she do that?
I don't know. The overall cost of the advanced training, plus the cats for the shoot days, and then the trainer fees was just shy of $9,000 to get Mr. Ash to hump Princess Lady, nine grand. That was a lot. And I feel like I want to call that woman. What was her name? The trainer's name? Denise.
Denise. And I want to be like, how did you do it? Was it a series of treats like every time Roswell stepped on potato, you got a treat? And then how do you get potato to stay put? I don't know. I don't know. These are questions for Denise. Do we need Denise on Revenge?
I want Denise on, and then I want an episode where we talk to a food historian. Odd jobs with Jenna and Angela. Yes. We have another spinoff podcast. We have so many. We have so many podcasts to do. Oh my goodness. We have so many factories to tour and podcasts to do.
Well, listen, lady, I think we should stick with the cats here, because I'm liking it. Okay. I'm liking the cat info. You want to see the whole story? I do. Okay. Because back in Scranton, Kevin and Oscar are working in accounting, and they're going to hear Angela's voice.
She's gotten home, and she is scolding Mr. Ash for his behavior. They have to watch. She didn't turn her computer off. She forgot to turn the kitty cam off. She did. They are watching her. She's hissing. She is communicating with the cats, with meows, and then she grooms Princess Lady with her
own tongue. There are so many things to unpack in this moment for you. First of all, I just love that she's like, excuse me, petals, I'm looking for Mr. Ash. Well, there you go. We know another cat's name is Pettles, but I don't think that's the question on everyone's minds. And I know that because we got a lot of mail about it. My favorite one was from Katie D, who said, I don't even know where to start.
So Angela, the cat cam scene, please explain. Well, Katie, let me tell you, Ken said to me, I want you to know you don't have to lick a cat today. Oh, yeah. He said, camera's going to be far away. I said, Ken, are you sure? He goes, yeah, yeah, no, you're not going to have to lick a cat today. No.
所以，安吉拉，猫咪摄像头的场景，请解释一下。好吧，凯蒂，老实说，肯对我说，我想让你知道今天你不需要舔猫。哦，真的。他说，摄像头会离得很远。我说，肯，你确定吗？他说，对，对，不，你今天不用舔猫。不用。
I was like, oh, okay. He goes, you can fake it. We'll be able to sell it. I said, okay. So we do a few takes and he comes up to me kind of meekishly and I said, Ken. And he goes, oh, you're just kind of moving a little bit closer with the camera. I said, I knew it. I knew it.
当时我想，哦，好吧。他说，你可以假装。我们能演过去。我说，好吧。于是我们拍了好几条，他有点战战兢兢地向我走来，我说，肯。然后他说，哦，你只是把摄像头稍微靠近了一点点。我说，我早就知道了。我早就知道了。
I knew it. So in one take, I actually licked the cat's face. I did it. And I felt bad for the cat because the cat's eyes were like, you know, did you get hair in your mouth? Yes. Of course I did. It was a very hairy cat.
我早就知道了。所以在其中一条里，我真的舔了猫的脸。我真的这么做了。而且我为那只猫感到难过，因为那只猫的眼神仿佛在说，你知道的，你嘴里弄到猫毛了吗？对。我当然弄到了。那是一只毛很多的猫。
Randy. Did it taste weird? I don't remember it tasting anyway, just being fuzzy. Randy told me that just in case I might lick the cat, listen, these guys knew they were going to ask me all along. They knew it. You think so? Oh, yeah.
兰迪。味道奇怪吗？我不记得有什么特别的味道了，只觉得毛茸茸的。兰迪告诉我，万一我可能要舔猫的话，听着，这些人其实从一开始就知道他们会要求我这么做。他们心里清楚。你觉得呢？哦，是的。
I think so. I think they were going to try to get one shot. Yeah. What do you think? Yeah. Randy said, so in case you were going to have to maybe lick the cat, Denise Sanders the trainer gave potato a special bath and blow dry before she came to set that day. Oh.
我也这么认为。我觉得他们本来就打算拍这么一个镜头。对。你觉得呢？对。兰迪说，所以万一你可能需要舔猫，训猫师丹妮丝·桑德斯在那天来到片场之前，给波特洛洗了个特殊的澡，还吹干了毛。哦。
Potato got a blow out. Fresh shower. Well, that's nice. So yes, I did lick the cat, but only once. The rest of them were fakey licks. I guess as the camera pans in, I don't know which one's the real one. So you don't know if they use the real lick or the fake lick? I don't know.
波特洛做了一个吹风造型。洗了个新鲜澡。那挺好的。所以是的，我确实舔了猫，但只舔了一次。剩下的都是假舔。我猜随着摄像头摇近，我也不知道哪一个是真的。所以你不知道他们用的是真舔还是假舔？我不知道。
Oh. Now, why would the camera be able to pan in if it was like a nanny cam? You'd think it would just be one locked off shot. Yes. You know. These are things I should have brought up in the moment. I should have had you with me. We did a lot of rehearsals.
哦。话说回来，如果这像是一个保姆摄像头，为什么镜头能摇近呢？你本来会觉得那应该是一个固定的镜头。是的。你知道的。这些都是我当时应该提出来的事情。我当时真该把你带在身边。我们排练了很多次。
They were pitching different things to me that Angela would do to try to bond with her cats. They were all on the ground, roll over, pretend to groom myself. And then they were like, does Angela talk to her cats? How does she talk to her cats? And then they pitched the sort of hiss thing. And then I had to practice different hisses, guys. They were very good.
他们向我提出了各种不同的想法，关于安吉拉会做些什么来试图和她的猫培养感情。它们都在地上打滚，假装给自己梳理毛发。然后他们就问，安吉拉会和她的猫说话吗？她是怎么和她的猫说话的？然后他们提出了那种发出嘶嘶声的点子。接着我必须练习不同的嘶嘶声，伙计们。他们非常棒。
I thought your cat sounds were great. Thank you. I mean, I feel like Ken and I really bonded this day because I was like, Ken, tell me, what do you like? Do you like this one? Or do you like? Or do you like? Yeah.
我觉得你的猫叫声模仿得很棒。谢谢。我的意思是，我觉得我和肯这一天真的很有默契，因为我当时说，肯，告诉我，你喜欢哪个？你喜欢这个吗？还是你喜欢？或者你喜欢？对。
And then you'd be like, oh, I like the second, and I'm like, okay. I like it that you scolded your cats in their own language. Thank you. I thought it showed your bond with them. Jenna, this brought me down a rabbit hole of Googling, do people really lick their cats? Apparently if you foster kittens, some people share online that they have licked a kitten's face if it's separated from its mom. What do you know about this?
然后你会说，哦，我喜欢第二个，我说，好吧。我喜欢你用它们自己的语言训斥你的猫。谢谢。我觉得这体现了你和它们的感情。珍娜，这让我陷入了一个疯狂搜索的深渊，人们真的会舔他们的猫吗？显然，如果你寄养过小猫，有些人会在网上分享说，如果小猫和猫妈妈分开了，他们曾舔过小猫的脸。你对这个有什么了解？
You foster kittens. I've done it. You've licked a cat's face. I have. I knew it. I was like, I bet Jenna has licked a cat's face. Yeah. So I worked in cat fostering for three years, and I fostered many kittens who had been separated
你寄养过小猫。我做过。你舔过猫的脸。我舔过。我就知道。当时我想，我敢打赌珍娜一定舔过猫的脸。对。所以我从事猫咪寄养工作三年，我寄养过许多在非常非常小的年纪就和猫妈妈分开的小猫。
from their moms at a very, very young age. And you know, I'm trying to socialize them, and I would just lick them between their eyes on their little forehead, give them a few little licks. That's what I read. Yes. Not with adult cats, but with little kittens. With kittens. That are very young and separated from their mom.
你知道的，我试图让他们社会化，我会在他们两眼之间的小额头上舔一下，给他们小小的舔几下。这就是我读到的。是的。不是对成年猫，而是对小猫。对小猫。非常年幼且与猫妈妈分开的小猫。
Yes. And it brings some great comfort, and they purr. That's what I read. I knew you would know. And I will say, I have also licked an adult cat. Okay. My cat, Andi, he had been sick, and he was an adult, and I licked between his eyes to give him some comfort.
是的。这会带给它们一些极大的安慰，它们会发出呼噜声。这就是我读到的。我就知道你会懂。而且我要说，我也舔过成年猫。好吧。我的猫，安迪，它生病了，它是一只成年猫，我在它的双眼之间舔了一下，为了给它一些安慰。
So yeah. I don't know. I mean, people let their dogs lick their faces, and I don't know, when you have a pet, they become like a member of the family. I think it's kind of like, listen, I'm not going to go over to anyone's house and start licking their animals. And I don't love when someone else's dog licks my face, but I don't care when my own dog does it.
所以，是的。我不知道。我的意思是，人们让他们的狗舔自己的脸，而且我不知道，当你养了宠物，它们就像是家庭的一员。我觉得这有点像，听着，我不会去任何人家里开始舔他们的动物。我也不喜欢别人的狗舔我的脸，但我不在乎我自己的狗这么做。
Right? Just like how your own kid's poop and vomit doesn't bother you, but I don't want some other kid to poop on me. Well no. I don't know what that is. I don't know why. It's like, when it's your family, you don't care. Well, I want you to know, when I looked this up online, there's a big debate about when
对吧？就像你不在乎自己孩子的便便和呕吐物一样，但我可不想让别人的小孩拉在我身上。好吧，不。我不知道那是什么。我不知道为什么。这就像，当它是你的家人时，你根本不在乎。好吧，我想让你知道，当我上网查这个时，关于什么时候、在哪里以及如何通过舔猫来培养感情，存在着激烈的争论，而且伙计们，显然，人类可以购买各种各样的假舌头，是的，用来舔猫。
and where and how to bond by licking your cat, and also guys, apparently, there's a whole industry of fake tongues that humans can purchase, yes, to lick their cats. Okay. So yes, there's also a little thing that you can put on your finger that's like sort of meant to simulate an adult cat's tongue. And if you foster kittens, you can get that and then you can rub that between their eyes. That's the thing you can get to. Cassie's in the booth.
好吧。所以，是的，还有一个可以套在手指上的小东西，有点像是在模拟成年猫的舌头。如果你寄养小猫，你可以买那个，然后你可以用它在它们两眼之间摩擦。那是你可以买到的东西。卡西在录音室里。
Cassie, you just fostered a bunch of kittens. Did you lick any of them? I didn't. I didn't know this was a thing, but maybe next round I'll try it. Or you can just get the little finger brush thing that came out while I was like mid-fostering and I did move to the finger brush eventually. Yeah, I'll get that. There was one that haunted me.
卡西，你刚刚寄养了一群小猫。你舔过它们中的任何一只吗？我没有。我不知道还有这回事，但也许下一轮我会试试。或者你也可以买那个小指刷，它在我正处于寄养期的时候推出了，我最后确实换用了指刷。对，我要买那个。有一个东西让我挥之不去。
It's a thing that you can, well, I won't be able to unsee it. It's a fake tongue that you can put in your mouth like a pacifier and then you can lick your cat. It can just be on your finger. That's what she said. Oh my God. I'm showing Jenna. Oh my God.
那是一个你可以……好吧，我再也无法抹去这个画面了。那是一个假舌头，你可以像安抚奶嘴一样把它含在嘴里，然后你就可以舔你的猫了。它也可以只戴在你的手指上。她是这么说的。哦，天哪。我正在给珍娜看。哦,天哪。
Introducing Licky Brush. I'm sorry. Cassie. I knew each other as a form of social bonding. As a human, you're left out of this intimate ritual with Licky Brush. It's also, they have like a big mussely man with a Licky Brush in his mouth. A pacifier. It's a pacifier that has a tongue on it and he's cradling his cat like a baby and then
隆重推出 Licky Brush（舔猫刷）。对不起。卡西。猫咪之间通过互相舔毛作为一种社会结合的形式。作为人类，你却被排斥在 Licky Brush 的这种亲密仪式之外。而且，他们还有一个肌肉发达的硬汉，嘴里含着一个 Licky Brush。一个安抚奶嘴。那是一个带有舌头的安抚奶嘴，他像抱婴儿一样抱着他的猫，然后……
like licking it and it's just that they picked someone I would not expect. I mean. I want you to know I saw that and I have been waiting to show you. I was like, I'm not even going to tell her. I want her to see it. I want to watch her react to it because I was like, what, what is happening? What did I just click on? Wow.
就像舔它一样，关键是他们选了一个我完全意想不到的人。我是说。我想让你知道我看到了那个，我一直在等着给你看。我当时想，我甚至不告诉她。我要让她亲眼看到。我想看她的反应，因为我当时想，什么，这到底是怎么回事？我刚刚点开了什么？哇。
Okay. Well, I guess it can take the idea of bonding with your cat to a whole new level. They make them for your fingers is what I want to say. To finish out this cat storyline, Angela returns to the office and she sees her computer is on and she's like, oh my gosh, has that been on the whole time? And Kevin and Oscar are like, what, I don't, we were just, we don't have no idea what you're talking about. Oscar has a talking head where he says he needs to erase that image from his head.
好吧。好吧，我想这确实把与猫培养感情的概念提升到了一个全新的水平。我想说的是，他们还为你的手指制作了这种产品。为了结束这条猫咪的故事线，安吉拉回到办公室，看到她的计算机开着，她心想，哦天哪，这个一直开着吗？凯文和奥斯卡则说，什么，我不知道，我们只是，我们完全不知道你在说什么。奥斯卡有一个采访镜头，他说他需要把那个画面从他的脑海中抹去。
But then Angela coughs up a hairball. Well, let's hear about that. I cough up a tiny hair, guys, right? It's like a little hair, but you know what? You've had your cat like cough up a hairball, right? It's so violent. It's like, yeah. Yeah.
但接着安吉拉咳出一个毛球。好吧，让我们来听听这个。我咳出了一小撮毛，伙计们，对吧？就像一小撮毛，但你知道吗？你见过你的猫咳出毛球，对吧？那太剧烈了。就像，是的。是的。
It's so incredibly like the first time you get a cat and they do it, you're like, oh my God. I don't know what's happening. It's so intense. So once again, Ken and I and Mindy, we're talking about how big do you go here, right? How big do I really, because you have two choices. Either Angela Martin has to do that like, yeah, or it's like way more subtle. And so I practiced a few different ways and this is the one they liked where basically
这太令人难以置信了，就像你第一次养猫，而它们做了这个动作时，你会想，哦，天哪。我不知道发生了什么。太强烈了。所以再一次，我和肯还有明迪，我们在讨论这里要表现得有多夸张，对吧？我到底应该表现得有多夸张，因为你有两种选择。要么安吉拉·马丁必须做出那种，呃，的反应，要么就得隐蔽得多。所以我练习了几种不同的方式，这是他们最喜欢的一种，基本上……
I'm just pulling one hair off my tongue and it's like, what is it? Was it the cat? Is it something else? It was the cat. It was the cat. It was the cat. It was. But I had to do it enough to sell it to Oscar and not so much that it was like a total cartoon.
我只是从舌头上扯下一根毛，然后就像是，这是什么？是猫的吗？还是别的什么？是猫的。是猫的。是猫的。是的。但我必须做得足够到位，才能让奥斯卡相信，又不能夸张得像个纯粹的动画片。
That was my work day, guys. That was my day that day. Hey, you're going to crawl around on the ground, pretend to be a cat, hiss at cats, lick a cat and then cough up a hairball. Mom, would you do it work today? Welcome to Hollywood. Should we go to Nashua? We do because Pam has talked Michael into giving his presentation because then maybe
这就是我的工作日，伙计们。那就是我那一天的生活。嘿，你要在地上爬来爬去，假装是一只猫，向猫发出嘶嘶声，舔猫，然后咳出一个毛球。妈妈，你今天在工作时都做了什么？欢迎来到好莱坞。我们该去纳舒厄了吗？我们得去，因为潘说服了迈克尔去进行他的演讲，因为这样或许……
they'll all talk about how great Michael was and Holly will hear about it, right? That's the way you show AJ, right? Yes. And you know what? At the beginning, it's going great. It is. He's doing a fantastic job. Just listen to all of his movie references.
他们都会讨论迈克尔有多棒，而霍莉会听到这个消息，对吧？这就是你向AJ展示的方式，对吧？是的。你知道吗？一开始，一切进展顺利。确实如此。他做得棒极了。只要听听他所有的电影梗就知道了。
Good morning, Vietnam. Ah, sales, sales is what brings us together today. How do we deal with clients who say, frankly, my dear, I don't give a damn about paper and get them to show us the money? Well, we are going to find out today. I had written this down. It's so interesting that you played that clip because I wondered, do our younger viewers get all of the references in Michael's opening remarks?
早安，越南。啊，销售，销售正是今天将我们凝聚在一起的原因。我们如何对待那些坦白说，亲爱的，我才不在乎纸张的客户，并让他们把钱拿出来？好吧，我们今天就要找到答案。我把这个写下来了。你播放那个片段真是太有趣了，因为我想知道，我们的年轻观众能听懂迈克尔开场白中的所有梗吗？
Do they know these movies? Good morning, Vietnam. Princess Bride, Gone with the Wind and Jerry McGuire. I guess this is Michael's taste in movies. But do people know all those today? I mean, you've got to know Princess Bride, right? I think. I don't know.
他们知道这些电影吗？《早安，越南》、《公主新娘》、《乱世佳人》和《甜心先生》。我猜这就是迈克尔的电影品味。但如今人们都知道所有这些吗？我的意思是，你总得知道《公主新娘》吧？我想。我不知道。
I don't know. But he's got them. They're laughing. They love his, like, voices he's doing. Nashua likes Michael from the receptionist to his opening remarks. They're eating out of the palm of his hand. If only he could get over this holly thing. He would finally have a day where he was the king of comedy like he's always wanted.
我不知道。但观众懂。他们在笑。他们喜欢他模仿的那些声音。纳舒厄分公司的人从前台到开场白都很喜欢迈克尔。他们简直对他的话言听计从。要是他能克服这个霍莉的问题就好了。他终于能有一天成为他一直渴望的喜剧之王了。
Those 30 seconds you just heard are the best that it is, because that's how quickly it falls apart. Because Michael zeroes in on AJ. He can't help it. Salesman. Salespeople. He's going to pick a random salesperson. You there, sir.
你刚刚听到的那30秒是最好的时光，因为事情崩溃得就是这么快。因为迈克尔把矛头对准了AJ。他控制不住自己。推销员。销售人员。他要随便挑一个销售人员。就是你，先生。
You. Mm-hmm. What's it like to be you? Oh, here we go. Yeah. And then Michael has a full-on panic attack. He winds up on the ground and he crawls out of the room. Mm-hmm.
你。嗯哼。做你是一种什么样的体验？哦，开始了。是的。然后迈克尔开始全面恐慌发作。他倒在了地上，然后从房间里爬了出去。嗯哼。
Leaving Pam. Yeah. Well, before we get to what Pam is going to do, I wanted to shout out a few crew cameos. Oh, okay. So sitting next to AJ, the woman who asked the question about discounts from distributors, that was Mary Wall. Yes. And she was a member of our production staff and she is delightful and wonderful.
留下了潘。嗯哼。好吧，在我们讲到潘要做什么之前，我想感谢几位客串的剧组人员。哦，好吧。所以坐在AJ旁边的那位问及经销商折扣问题的女士，那是玛丽·沃尔。是的。她曾是我们制作团队的一员，她既讨人喜欢又非常棒。
She has gone on to become a producer and a director. She currently is working on a documentary called The Fan Connection. You can actually check it out at fanconnectionmovie.com. You can see a trailer. It's all about the hockey fans in Buffalo. Oh, I would love that. And their commitment to their hockey team and you know I love hockey. So anyway, check out the trailer, guys.
她后来成为了一名制片人和导演。她目前正在制作一部名为《粉丝连接》（The Fan Connection）的纪录片。你其实可以在 fanconnectionmovie.com 上查看。你可以看到预告片。讲的全是布法罗的冰球球迷。哦，我会喜欢这个的。以及他们对冰球队的忠诚，而且你知道我喜欢冰球。总之，去看看预告片吧，伙计们。
I love sports documentaries. Mm-hmm. Love them. And then sitting in the row in front of AJ with the red hair was Claire Scanlon, our editor. And Pam's going to call her Freckles. Claire is a full-on badass, amazing editor and now prolific director. Yes.
我喜欢体育纪录片。嗯哼。非常喜欢。然后坐在AJ前面那一排、留着红头发的是克莱尔·斯坎伦，我们的剪辑师。潘会叫她“小雀斑”。克莱尔是个彻头彻尾的狠角色、了不起的剪辑师，现在是一位多产的导演。是的。
I have another guest star I want to mention, Michael McCartney. He played the other Nashua employee who says, what does this have to do with sales when Michael is disintegrating? He has a very extensive resume. He is the producer and director of the series The Millionaires on Amazon Prime, but here's what I want to tell you. What? This is the first time I've seen this and all of my Googling of all of our guest stars.
我还有另一位想提的客串明星，迈克尔·麦卡特尼。他饰演了另一个纳舒厄的员工，当迈克尔崩溃时，他说“这跟销售有什么关系”。他的履历非常丰富。他是亚马逊Prime剧集《百万富翁》的制片人和导演，但这是我想告诉你的。什么？这是我所有关于客串明星的搜索中第一次看到这个。
Well now I don't know what to expect. Michael McCartney has been on Law and Order, Law and Order SVU, and Law and Order Criminal Intent, The Trifecta, Holy Cow, all three. Not on Monk. Not on Monk. There's still room. There's still room. Future guest star.
现在我不知道该期待什么了。迈克尔·麦卡特尼演过《法律与秩序》、《法律与秩序：特殊受害者》以及《法律与秩序：犯罪意图》，三连冠，天哪，全演过。没演过《神探阿蒙》。没演过《神探阿蒙》。还有空间。还有空间。未来的客串明星。
If you could be on all three Law and Orders and Monk, I'm going to drive to your house and give you a cake. So when I was trading emails with Rob, I was like, Rob, you've got to share what it was like in that room when Steve, as Michael, is falling apart and singling you out. I mean, I don't know. How did you do that? How did you get through it? And here's what he had to say.
如果你能把三部《法律与秩序》和《神探阿蒙》全演一遍，我要开车去你家送你一个蛋糕。所以当我跟罗布发邮件交流时，我说，罗布，你必须分享一下，当史蒂夫饰演的迈克尔崩溃并单单挑出你时，那个房间里的情况是什么样的？我的意思是，我不知道。你是怎么做到的？你是怎么熬过这一切的？他是这么说的。
My memories of shooting that scene in the conference room with Steve are mostly about just trying not to laugh because sometimes I just start laughing when people are funny because really, I feel like a lot of times on comedy shows, you're trying to make the other person laugh. In a way, you're kind of trying to f*** with them a little bit. So anyway, I was just trying to keep a straight face because Steve is so funny and Jenna is so funny and everybody on the show is so funny. And I also get very nervous.
我关于在会议室里和史蒂夫拍摄那个场景的记忆，大多都是关于努力憋笑的，因为有时当别人很搞笑时，我就会开始笑，因为真的，我觉得很多时候在喜剧节目里，你都在试图逗笑对方。从某种程度上说，你其实有点在捉弄他们。所以总之，我只是在努力保持严肃的面孔，因为史蒂夫太搞笑了，珍娜也太搞笑了，剧里的每个人都太搞笑了。而且我也变得非常紧张。
I get nervous going into a new show and there's this whole other culture there already established. When you're a guest actor on a show, it's different because you don't know what you're walking into. So I was a little bit nervous and Steve is just iconic. Steve is just so funny. And when he's kind of coming at me like that, he's putting me down and ignoring me and calling me names in a very funny way, but it's all so funny. So mostly trying not to laugh.
我进入一个新的剧组时会感到紧张，那里已经建立了一整套完全不同的文化。当你是一部剧的客串演员时，情况是不一样的，因为你不知道你要面对的是什么。所以我有点紧张，而史蒂夫简直是标志性的。史蒂夫实在是太搞笑了。当他那样针对我时，他在贬低我、忽略我，用一种非常搞笑的方式叫我各种绰号，但这一切都太搞笑了。所以主要就是在努力憋笑。
I loved his description of what it's like to be a guest actor on a show, walking into the world and it's a comedy and it's supposed to be funny, but then you're not supposed to laugh. I just, I related to all of that so much. I did too. Well, we also asked him, does he still get recognized? As AJ, he's been on, what did you say, 140, 140 movies and TV shows. Does he get recognized as AJ?
我很喜欢他对身为一部剧的客串演员的描述，走进那个世界，那是一部喜剧，本该是搞笑的，但你却不能笑。我真的对这一切感同身受。我也是。好吧，我们还问了他，他现在还会被认出来吗？作为AJ，他演过，你刚才说的是什么，140部，140部电影和电视剧。他会被认出是AJ吗？
Let's find out. Do I get recognized as AJ from the office? Are you kidding me? Yes. Yes, a lot. And I'm so thankful for it. It is very fun to be recognized no matter what people tell you. It is fun because it's, you know, it's people love it.
让我们来听听。我会因为《办公室》里的AJ而被认出来吗？你在开玩笑吗？是的。是的，经常。对此我非常感激。无论别人对你说什么，被人认出来总是很有趣的。这很有趣，因为你知道，人们喜欢它。
They love the show and that's fun. You know, like everyone had an opinion about Michael and Holly's relationship and I was just standing in the way so I would get threatened by strangers. You know, it was crazy. In fact, people used to come up to me out of the blue. I remember people would sometimes whisper in my ear, like come up behind me and say, you stay away from Holly, you stay away from Holly. And what's crazy is that my wife in real life, her name is Holly.
他们喜欢这部剧，这就很有趣。你知道的，就像每个人对迈克尔和霍莉的关系都有看法，而我正好挡在中间，所以我会被陌生人威胁。你知道的，这太疯狂了。事实上，人们曾经莫名其妙地走到我面前。我记得有时人们会在我耳边低语，比如从我身后走过来对我说，你离霍莉远点，你离霍莉远点。而疯狂的是，我在现实生活中的妻子，她的名字就叫霍莉。
So I would have to decide in about two seconds, okay, is this someone that used to date my wife in real life that I should murder or is this just a fan of the office acting like a creeper? I love that his wife's name is Holly. I know. That's insane. That is crazy, though, that people go up to him and they're like, leave Holly alone. And he's like, wait, wait, that's my wife.
所以我不得不在大约两秒钟内做出决定，好吧，这究竟是一个曾经和我现实中的妻子约会过、我应该谋杀掉的人，还是只是一个行为诡异的《办公室》粉丝？我太喜欢他妻子叫霍莉这件事了。我知道。这太疯狂了。不过，人们走到他面前说“离霍莉远点”，而他却说“等等，等等，那是我的妻子”。
Oh, you're. Oh, okay. Oh, I know what you are. Amazing. Well, thank you, Rob, for sending in your audio clips. It was so nice of you. I love listening to your voice. I think he has a soothing, pleasant voice Rob.
哦，你是。哦，好吧。哦，我知道你是干什么的了。太棒了。好吧，谢谢罗布发来你的音频剪辑。你太好了。我喜欢听你的声音。我觉得他的声音听起来很平静、很悦耳，罗布。
She's not kidding. While we were recording this episode and you sent in your audio clips, Jenna was like, I just love the sound of his voice. I know. You get tons of voiceover work because I would buy anything you're selling. Hey. Yeah. How about them apples?
她可没开玩笑。在我们录制这一集、你发来音频剪辑的时候，珍娜就说，我太喜欢他的声音了。我知道。你会接到大量的配音工作，因为你卖什么我都会买。嘿。是的。感觉怎么样？
So Jenna, Michael has left, Pam is in charge. She goes right into Force Gump. Lady, this was one of my favorite shooting days ever, having to take over the presentation. It was so fun to watch you. It was hilarious. I loved watching Pam try to do Michael's movie bits. Angela, you know I'm not great with accents or impressions. I cannot tell you how hard I worked on that Forrest Gump voice.
所以珍娜，迈克尔走了，潘负责了。她直接切换到了《阿甘正传》。天哪，这是我有生以来最喜欢的拍摄日之一，接管演讲环节。看你表演太有趣了。太爆笑了。我太喜欢看潘模仿迈克尔的电影桥段了。安吉拉，你知道我不太擅长口音或模仿。我无法告诉你我在那个《阿甘》的声音上付出了多少努力。
Oh my gosh, lady. So hard. Lady, I thought you were doing a bit to be bad, right? Yes. And that is what Mindy and Ken Quapas thought on set. They were crying, laughing when I did it. Mindy said it was genius that I was doing it so bad. Yeah.
哦，天哪，天哪。太难了。天哪，我还以为你是在故意装得不好笑呢，对吧？是的。这也是明迪和肯·库帕斯在片场时的想法。我表演的时候，他们都笑哭了。明迪说我演得这么烂简直是个天才的表现。是的。
I was texting with her because I was like Mindy, do you remember this episode? And she said, yes, I thought you were so funny that day. Your Forrest Gump, it was such a funny choice, you know, to be bad. And I was like Mindy, that was my literal best effort. My acting limitations made me genius. Like that's one of those things where like if I tried to be bad, it wouldn't have been as good as me giving it my best effort. I can't do it better than that.
我和她发短信来着，因为我当时问，明迪，你还记得这一集吗？她说，记得，我觉得那天你太搞笑了。你的《阿甘》，那真是一个非常搞笑的选择，你知道，就是故意演得很烂。然后我说，明迪，那可是我字面意义上全力以赴的表现啊。我的演技局限让我成了天才。这就属于那种情况，如果我是故意演得烂的话，可能还不如我全力以赴的效果好。我没法比那个演得更好了。
I need to hear it. I need to hear it. I got to hear it. I got to hear it. I'm getting my laugh. I got to hear it. I got now with that information in my brain, I've got to hear it because I thought like Mindy that you were doing a bit now at like, I'm going to read it.
我得听听。我得听听。我得听听。我得听听。我要笑出来了。我得听听。现在我脑子里有了这个信息，我必须得听听，因为我跟明迪一样，以为你当时是在玩梗，就像，我要开始读了。
My Forrest Gump kind of crappy, but no, it was your best effort, honey. I listened to his voice in my head over and over and over and over again and I tried to mimic it perfectly. I have never loved you more knowing now that that Forrest Gump was your earnest best effort. It was. Sales is like a box of chocolates. You never know which vendor you're going to get. Forrest Gump.
我的阿甘有点烂，但不是的，亲爱的，那真的是你全力以赴的表现。我在脑海里一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍地听着他的声音，我试图完美地模仿它。现在知道那个《阿甘》是你最真诚、最尽力的表现后，我比任何时候都更爱你。确实如此。生活就像一盒巧克力。你永远不知道你会抽到哪个供应商。阿甘。
Lady. That's the cutest thing ever. That is the cutest thing. Oh my gosh. Look at Devin and Cassie. They're cracking up. You guys, is that adorable? Come on.
天哪。这是有史以来最可爱的事情。太可爱了。哦，天哪。看看德文和卡西。他们笑裂了。伙计们，这难道不是很可爱吗？拜托。
So cute. We love it. Thank you guys. Thank you. I love doing that scene. I loved the chainsaw. I loved the chainsaw. It was one of my most, you know, this was one of the few times when I was called upon to
太可爱了。我们爱死这个了。谢谢你们。谢谢。我非常喜欢拍那个场景。我喜欢电锯。我喜欢电锯。这是我最……你知道的，这是少数几次我被要求去……
do like, what would you call it? Like. A group? To be the comedy protagonist. Yes. I was usually the receiver of comedy. My job on this show was to amplify a comedic moment with my deadpan reaction. But in this case, I got to pitch the comedy ball and it felt really good.
去做什么呢？你会怎么称呼它？就像。一个团体？成为喜剧的主角。是的。我通常是喜剧的接收者。我在这个剧里的工作是通过我死鱼眼般的反应来放大喜剧时刻。但在这种情况下，我得以抛出喜剧之球，感觉真的很好。
Other people reacted off of you. Yes. And it was fun. Well, one of my favorite things to watch play out in any movie or TV show is when a character decides to step up to the plate and then bales. So at the end when Pam got out the chainsaw and was like, cutting down the competition. Yeah. The bale is my favorite.
其他人根据你的反应来演。是的，而且很有趣。好吧，在任何电影或电视剧中，我最喜欢看的剧情之一就是一个角色决定挺身而出，然后却临阵脱逃。所以到最后，当潘拿出电锯并说，砍掉竞争对手时。是的。临阵脱逃是我的最爱。
She's like, I'm out. Well, during all this, Michael has gone over to Holly's desk. He's stroking her yellow cardigan. He cuts half of the sleeve off. Yeah. That made me laugh so hard, Jenna. And then he pushes the chair in and the screensaver pops up of Martin Short, which is so perfect. As Ed Grimley.
她就像是，我不干了。好吧，在这期间，迈克尔走到了霍莉的桌子旁。他抚摸着她的黄色开衫。他剪下了半个袖子。是的。这把我笑得太惨了，珍娜。然后他把椅子推回去，屏幕保护程序弹出了马丁·肖特的画面，简直太完美了。扮演埃德·格里姆利。
Yes. You know what Randy Cordray told me? What? That little moment, like that was the whole thing. He said we had this graphic artist on staff, his name was Michael Marcus, and he had to build that on-screen computer graphic where there were these documents on the home page, that picture of Martin Short. They had to get permission to license that photo from Getty Images.
是的。你知道兰迪·科德雷跟我说过什么吗？什么？那个小小的时刻，就像那是整件事的关键。他说我们剧组有一个平面设计师，名叫迈克尔·马克思，他必须在电脑主页上制作那个屏幕图形，上面有那些文档，还有那张马丁·肖特的照片。他们必须获得盖蒂图片社的授权才能使用那张照片。
I mean, that little moment, that was someone's day creating that. Right. I just, I love watching the show and thinking of those details. Well, to finish out the Nashua branch storyline, Pam and Michael, they pack up, I love when Pam was like, don't look up, don't look up, don't look up when they're packing up the car, and they go to a diner, and Michael confesses that A, he cut off part of her sweater, and that he saw a dear Michael folder on her desktop and he copied it, he's got it. And Pam says, you can't read that, but I can read it.
我是说，那个小小的时刻，那是某人花了一整天创作出来的。对。我就是，我喜欢看这部剧并去思考这些细节。好吧，为了结束纳舒厄分公司的剧情，潘和迈克尔收拾东西，我喜欢潘说“别抬头，别抬头，别抬头”当他们在收拾车子的时候，他们去了一家餐馆，迈克尔承认了：第一，他剪掉了她毛衣的一部分；第二，他在她的桌面上看到了一个“致迈克尔”的文件夹，他复制了，他拿到了。潘说，你不能读那个，但我能读。
Right. Pam can read it. And I won't tell you what the specifics are, but I can tell you if she still likes you. We had a lot of fan mail about that, Emma S, Eric M, and Zachary C all wanted to know, was there a letter or was I just pretending to read something? There was a letter. I wondered that too. Phil Shea wrote a letter and I was very grateful because as I read it, it helped me get in
没错。潘可以读。我不会告诉你具体细节，但我可以告诉你她是否还喜欢你。我们收到了很多关于这一集的粉丝邮件，埃玛·S、埃里克·M和扎卡里·C都想知道，当时真的有一封信，还是我只是假装在读什么东西？确实有一封信。我也纳闷过。菲尔·谢写了一封信，我非常感激，因为当我阅读它时，它帮助我进入了……
a headspace because there were all these things I read, but then I knew I was going to tell Michael the scripted lines of like, it's not over. And it was great. It was so helpful as an actor to have not just a blank screen there. So thank you, Phil Shea, for writing me a letter. I wonder if Phil had to consult the writing staff and say, guys, I'm going to write this letter. Do you have any, or he just did that on his own?
一种状态，因为有所有这些我要读的东西，而且我知道接下来我要对迈克尔说出剧本里的台词，比如“还没结束呢”。这太棒了。作为演员，手头不只是一张空白屏幕，这真的太有帮助了。所以谢谢菲尔·谢给我写了一封信。我在想菲尔是不是得去咨询编剧团队，然后说，伙计们，我要写这封信。你们有什么意见吗，还是他自己直接就写了？
I think that was stuff he just did on his own. He was a very detail-oriented prop master. Yes. And he would often do that if we had a fakie piece of paper. A memo. Yeah. It was very detailed. Mm-hmm.
我觉得那是他自己做的事情。他是一个非常注重细节的道具师。是的，如果我们有一个假的纸条道具，他经常会这么做。一份备忘录。是的。非常详细。嗯哼。
I have a question for you because when I watch this, I am always like relating it back to like things happening. Would you have read it if you saw like something on your ex's computer, would you have read it? Yeah. Me too. Of course. 100%.
我有个问题想问你，因为当我看到这里时，我总是会把它和现实中发生的事情联系起来。如果你在前任的电脑上看到类似的东西，你会读它吗？会。我也是。当然会。100%会。
Yeah. I would have just sat down right then and there and read it. Correct. Okay. I feel better now. Yeah. Michael is thrilled to find out that it's not over with Holly and we're not sure yet what he's going to do with that information, but he's happy to know it.
对。我当时就会直接坐在那儿把它读完。没错。好吧。我现在感觉好多了。是的。迈克尔发现他和霍莉之间还没结束，对此他感到欣喜若狂，我们还不知道他要怎么处理这个信息，但他很高兴能知道这一点。
He feels like he has closure. Yeah, he does. We haven't talked about the rest of this birthday storyline. Well, listen, they're not doing very well. Jim and Dwight are still trying to brainstorm the perfect party for Kelly. Yeah. They're in the conference room. And Jim says, okay, so far, our ideal party consists of beer, fights to the death, cupcakes,
他觉得自己得到了了结。是的，他确实得到了。我们还没聊到生日剧情的其余部分。好吧，听着，他们进展得不太顺利。吉姆和德怀特仍在集思广益，想为凯莉策划一个完美的派对。是的。他们在会议室里。吉姆说，好吧，到目前为止，我们理想的派对包括啤酒、生死决斗、纸杯蛋糕……
blood pudding, blood, touch football, mating, charades, and yes, horse hunting. Yeah. And Dwight's like, you're right, forget horse hunting, it's stupid. Just only lose that one. All the rest are viable. Yeah. All the rest sound great. But ultimately, they actually find a theme.
血肠、血、触式橄榄球、交配、字谜游戏，还有，是的，狩猎马匹。是的。德怀特说，你说得对，忘掉狩猎马匹吧，太蠢了。唯独删掉这一个。其余的都行得通。是的。剩下的听起来都很棒。但最终，他们真的找到了一个主题。
Everyone gathers in the conference room, Kelly comes in, there's a cake, her name is spelled wrong, and there's a chiclet. You know what a chiclet is? I do. It's a piece of gum and it's a square. It's a little square piece of gum. I love a chiclet. I love a chiclet too.
大家聚集在会议室里，凯莉走了进来，有一个蛋糕，她的名字拼错了，还有一个奇落糖（Chiclet）。你知道什么是奇落糖吗？我知道。那是一块口香糖，它是正方形的。一小块正方形的口香糖。我喜欢奇落糖。我也喜欢奇落糖。
I like it that it has like a candy coating before I chew the gum. I like the crunch. Me too. Kelly wants to know what's up with the chiclet. Jim says, that's the best part. The chiclet represents a pillow. It's a pillow or a television. That's our theme.
我喜欢它在嚼口香糖之前有一层糖衣。我喜欢那种脆脆的口感。我也是。凯莉想知道那个奇落糖是怎么回事。吉姆说，这才是最棒的部分。奇落糖代表一个枕头。是一个枕头还是一台电视。这就是我们的主题。
A pillow or a television is their theme. She gets to decide one hour of TV or an hour of napping. What would you pick? I would, I don't know if I could sleep at work. I can't nap in general. I have to be sick in order to take a nap. Even if I've gotten three hours of sleep the night before, I can't nap. I get like wired tired.
枕头或电视就是他们的主题。她可以决定看一个小时的电视或者睡一个小时的觉。你会选哪个？我会，我不知道我能不能在工作时睡觉。我通常无法打盹。我必须生病了才能小睡一会儿。即使我前一晚只睡了三个小时，我也睡不着。我会处于那种异常兴奋又疲惫的状态。
So I would 100% pick an hour of TV. There's so much TV I haven't been able to watch lately because we've been working really hard on the book. So I mean, I'm in the middle of the white lotus. I'm in the middle of hacks. I only just finished Mare of Easttown. Do you hear how behind I am? Yeah.
所以我100%会选看一个小时的电视。最近有太多电视节目我都来不及看了，因为我们一直在努力写书。所以，我的意思是，我正在看《白莲花》看到一半。我正在看《绝望同行》（Hacks）看到一半。我刚刚才看完《东城梦魇》。你听得出我落后多少了吧？对。
So hour of TV, yes please. That sounds decadent to me. Also yeah, I can't sleep during the day. Something has to be wrong with me if I fall asleep during the day. Yeah. It's just like my body just won't do it. I do think this is a little bit of an old tech alert. What's the old tech?
所以一个小时的电视，太好了，求之不得。这对我来说听起来太奢侈了。还有，是的，我白天睡不着觉。如果我在白天睡着了，那一定是我身上出了什么毛病。是的。感觉我的身体就是不允許我这么做。我确实觉得这有点像个老旧科技警报。什么老旧科技？
They say that the chicklet represents a pillow or a television. And I think at work now we would just watch an hour on our phone or our computer. That's true. And also doesn't Stanley say there's nothing good on right now? Well Creed says Bonnie Hunts on. But it's that they're going to watch like live television. That's right. Not streaming anything.
他们说奇落糖代表一个枕头或一台电视。我觉得现在在工作时，我们大概只会用手机或电脑看一个小时。确实如此。而且斯坦利不是也说过“现在没什么好节目”吗？嗯，克里德说邦妮·亨特在播。但关键是他们要看的是那种直播电视。没错。而不是流媒体点播。
No streaming. So I would say their theme was a little bit of an old tech alert. I agree. Well, Kelly chooses nap. And she takes a little nap under the conference table. And while she does, Jim and Dwight sit on that little couch by reception and they eat their cake and they're very proud of themselves. And I want to point out this scene to everyone because John is doing a classic, fakey, edy
没有流媒体。所以我得说他们的主题有点像个老旧科技警报。我同意。好吧，凯莉选择了睡觉。她在会议室的桌子底下小睡了一会儿。在她睡觉的时候，吉姆和德怀特坐在前台旁边的那个小沙发上吃蛋糕，他们为自己感到非常骄傲。我想向大家指出这个场景，因为约翰在这个吃蛋糕的桥段里展现了一种经典的、虚假的、Edy式的表演技巧。
acting technique with this cake. He's shoving the food around the plate. He would take a big scoop of cake, but then he smushes it back down. And so by the time he puts it in his mouth, it just has a little frosting on it. Watch it. He goes for the cake three times and never actually eats a piece. At the beginning he eats like half a piece. You have to do this because otherwise you're going to get sick.
他在盘子里把食物推来推去。他会舀一大勺蛋糕，然后又把它压回去。所以等他把它放进嘴里时，上面其实只有一点点糖霜。注意看。他拿蛋糕的动作做了三次，但实际上从来没吃过一块。一开始他吃了一半的一小块。你必须这么做，否则你会生病的。
However, sitting next to him is Rainn Wilson who eats the cake. Because Rainn always ate in scenes. It didn't matter. Remember he ate so many bananas, he got sick. Yeah. When Rainn as Dwight does anything, he goes all out. And I feel like Rainn eats in scenes the way Brad Pitt eats in movies. Watch in Oceans 12.
然而，坐在他旁边的是雷恩·威尔逊，他在吃蛋糕。因为雷恩在场景里总是吃东西。这无所谓。还记得他吃了那么多香蕉，结果生病了吗？是的。当雷恩饰演的德怀特做任何事情时，他都是全力以赴的。我觉得雷恩在场景里吃东西的样子，就像布拉德·皮特在电影里吃东西一样。看看《十二罗汉》。
The guy is always eating. I wanted to know, like, is this a choice? You're constantly eating something. Watch Goodfellas. Do you see how much steak and pasta those guys eat? They dig in. Goodfellas makes me hungry. Yeah.
这家伙一直在吃。我想知道，这是一种选择吗？你一直在吃东西。看看《好家伙》。你看到那些家伙吃了多少牛排和面条吗？他们狼吞虎咽。看《好家伙》让我觉得饿。是的。
When I watch it, I get hungry. For sure. Guys, guess what? That was Lecture Circuit Part 2 with a little bit of movie extra stuff. We had, I felt like, a lot of interesting movie magic facts. A lot of cat grooming facts. And a forest gump impression. Not a bad day.
我看的时候也会觉得饿。肯定的。伙计们，猜怎么着？那是《讲座巡回演出》第二部分，带有一点电影幕后花絮。我们有，我觉得，很多有趣的电影幕后魔术事实。很多猫咪梳理毛发的冷知识。还有一个阿甘模仿秀。不算糟糕的一天。
Not too shabby. And next week is Blood Drive. Oh, yeah. I've got some good facts about the Blood Mobile. It was actually on the set. It was. It was in the parking lot. A real one.
还算过得去。下周是《献血车》。哦，是的。我有一些关于献血车的精彩花絮。它其实就在片场。是的。就在停车场。一辆真的。
Yep. Yep. I'll tell you all about it next week. See you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kieffer, and our associate
没错。没错。我下周会把一切都告诉你们。下周见。谢谢收听“办公室辣妈”。“办公室辣妈”由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔担任执行制片人。我们的制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉特恩的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版本的“办公室辣妈”，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。在 Stitcher Premium 上免费试用一个月，请使用优惠码 Office。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科伊。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。要收听《办公室女士》的无广告版，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。在 Stitcher Premium 免费试用一个月，请使用优惠码 Office。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。